uh we are uh back in the field again and
I think it's uh3 days after sewing now
although we had some rewing and
replanting so it's not quite accurate
because we have quite a few places which
we planted later so and that creat a
challenge now because we somehow need to
figure out uh when to harvest this field
and uh there are various ways to do this
and we have an expert here with us today
Martin gut who is our post har
specialist and also leads the E program
for so we'll ask him for help to help us
determine where we are and what we do
next okay so there as aim said there are
different ways to determine whether the
crop is ready for Harvest so uh the
easiest is basically to look at the
color of the grains so if you have 80%
of the Grain in a panicle colored straw
yellow then that's an indication that it
should be should be right another way to
to determine whether uh the crop is
ready for harvesting is look at the at
the hardness of the grains and the the
grains in the bottom of the panicle
should be in the hard do stage so when
you when you basically open the Grain
and you look at it it should still be a
little bit soft but not too soft like
like uh when you make a hot dough for
for cooking so when you squeeze it you
you your nail should probably cut the
grain rather than than mash it up so to
speak it should not be brittle yet so we
start with a visual estimate of of how
ready the crop is and we we we first
look at the the proportion of yellow
grains the proportion of straw yellow
grains now Martin has suggested an ideal
amount for Harvest would be 80% yellow
now in front of me here we always have
an issue as to whether it's
representative or not it's
probably 50 to 60% yellow something of
that order it's not quite ready
yet now a more objective and
professional way to assess how uh how
ready the crop is we'll be to measure
its moisture content yep and this is one
way to do that this is a moisture meter
So-Cal moist meter it measures the
resistance of the crop which is uh
basically dependent on the moisture
content and you have a small sample tray
so you take a a sample from a panicle at
least at 80% of the of the GR should be
St yellow that basically says 80% of one
panicker getting representative is
always a challenge there's almost no is
a challenge
all so so uh you take a small sample
like this fill it in there and then uh
what you do with this instrument
basically you crush it oops can I give
you
thisx it you you turn the knob and crush
it turn it all the way to the end and
then uh you measure the resistance and
that gets translated in the reading of
the moisture conted and this case it's
21.6% and what we're going to do is mix
The Greener one I've I've I've harvested
and because this is a way small sample
it's not really representative neither
for small plot nor for the field so what
you have to do is you have to in one
location you should do different at
least three different
measurements so now in this sample for
example you have a lot more green grains
than in the previous one so the reading
should be a lot higher
27.9% and you would take at least three
samples and then you have a button here
where you can average the readings and
then you get the average reading for
that uh location and then what you have
to do is basically also measure in a
representative way in the field because
the the crop doesn't mature evenly
everywhere in the
field we're facing the final tricky
decision to irrigate or not to get
irrigate that is the question so we're
considering how moist the soil is now
how moist is the soil now moist
right we're considering what the
weather's like what's the weather like
hot dry and we're considering how long
we'd expect until we Harvest and our
consensus is about
10 days to 2 weeks something of that
range it'll be close to to two weeks
time before you're back to do the
dude so we need this to last to to
finish properly I think it needs the two
weeks but it's moist it's heavy clay and
we do want our combine to stay on the
ground not to explore the
underground I
vote keep it
dry yeah I would have if it was an
experiment and I knew that we would be
doing hand harvesting I would put on
another irrigation just for safety but
we need to figure out that we have to
come in with a comine and so the
carrying capacity of that soil will be
the deciding factor and we can't delay
Harvest because we see some lodging
coming in so I'll go with the majority
wot yeah I agree so no more irrigation
let's see but I pray for a little bit of
rain tonight
maybe well on RAC and patterns I think
you'll probably have that have that wish
granted so there we have it we won't
irrigate again and we'll it'll be in
approximately 2 weeks we'll come back
and harvest about May
2nd